dans la danse c'est toutes les
sensations sensation de l'espace
sensation de temps
sensation échanges émotionnel avec ses
partenaires
c'est comme quand on fait l'amour
brecht commence avec le début il ya tout
le monde défunte un peu patient faut que
je me mette en marche
l'opéra de paris
l'arrivée de benjamin est un peu
déboussolés par mais par pas mal de
choses c'est quoi l'excellence de
l'opéra exactement moi je suis pas
encore satisfait de la façon dont ça
danse
j'espère que les danseurs vont être
réceptif et ceux qui seront réceptifs
sont ceux avec lesquels je vais
travailler c'est très compliqué je vais
finir mais la dernière minute ça c'est
sûr
si benjamin delaux choisissez pour
contrer belle pour qu'on donne de nous
j'arrive à faire une minute par exemple
une minute ainsi
il faut que chaque moment content parce
que ces moments là c'est pour vous pour
prendre du plaisir
il n'y a pas un danseur qui bouge comme
l'autre dans le ballet ils ont tous des
spécificités tous